okay so I'm about 14 years old and
school one day and the guy comes out to
meet my friends and gives us all a
floppy disk and says check us out
tonight when you go home so when we walk
from school I'm thinking this is really
dodgy so I decide to go to a friend's
house he's a son of a fat car and has a
PCS bedroom I don't have that so what
has bedroom put the floppy desk in the
PC open up the floppy desk and it's like
a treasure chest of porn really jackpot
this is awesome so let's be clever about
this let's hide all the images so if
someone finds the desk
they will think it's empty so isolate
all the energies rate click on the mouse
scroll down go to click hide but
accidentally somehow ends up press and
print no his computers on a home network
his mom the wife of a vet cars in this
family room with apprentice a piano for
the songs for the chart dog and that
Sunday the pen R starts to go so he does
gone for dead what would they do I'm
like don't panic
we dead no was on the desk we were on
the desks cop horrified and disgusted by
what we found we try to delete at all
but accidentally Press print so he's a
cool cool cool ok good cover story about
12 minutes later the printer still going
has mom coming up she wait she swear
never seen in for this and always before
it she just goes why is her non-stop
porn printing from the computer so my
friend just crumbles starts training
course is o joins fall
[Applause]
in Year seven when I was like 12 years
old my parents thought it would be a
great idea for me to learn English to
come to UK in a boarding school and I
felt I knew no English at all so one day
there wasn't a pillow in my bed
so I asked a roommate how that was said
so I could ask for one and she told me
it was called the dildo so I didn't know
so I was going to ask the matron but
that night the headmaster of the school
came to like me innocently and as polite
as I could went there to ask for a dead
lawyer I could sleep
so I was visiting my girlfriend by then
girlfriends family home for a birthday
and it was the weekend so we had a lazy
lion and spent some time celebrating get
rid of him okay so you're celebrating
and we get interrupted by him calling us
from downstairs because they're setting
for a party in the afternoon for a
family so we finish up quickly and I
take my contraception off and just throw
it casually in the chair so we go
downstairs we're helping out families
said to come and a little while later
hit a little him mom asks her nephew to
go grab some chairs for the guests okay
now we know the end Christmas story that
wasn't in everybody
years ago I used to work in a coffee
shop and I was making a flat white for a
customer which is the one with the nice
pretty little Fleurette pan on the top
oh yes but I was in a bit of a rush I
thought the coffee I've made was okay
and I was about to hand it to the
customer when my friend tapped on my
shoulder and said um you might want to
take a second look at that so I looked
down and sure enough instead of a nice
pretty Fleurette pattern I'd managed to
make a penis and this put me in a bit of
a dilemma I was like do I like give it
to him and hope he's not noticed or do I
say I'm sorry so I put a cocky new
coffee so I decided to just give it to
him and hope he didn't notice and he
looked down at it and went oh I've never
had one of those in my coffee
[Laughter]
so I used to look after some charity
shops in the north of England and I got
a phone call from a concerned member of
the public and saying there was a
dubious object in a window display so I
rang the charity shop and spoke to the
elderly volunteer on the phone and I
said to her can he just taught me
through what's in your window display
and she said oh yes we've had a lady
come in the other day and she's donated
this fantastic box of gym equipment so
we've kind of like put the mannequin in
the window we put the shorts on him and
then we've got the bench press and we've
got the little springy thing and we also
got am a neck massager as well oh I
tried to get around it a little bit and
I said so well we're not really allowed
to sell electrical goods and she said oh
well there's no need to worry because
it's battery-operated all right and she
said to don't worry it does work cuz me
and the rest of the volunteers have been
trying it in the back room I said to her
I don't know how to tell you this Sandra
but I think it might be a vibrator there
was a moment's pause on the edge of the
phone and then she just said my face get
to the window
[Applause]
in bed with an ex-lover of mine and we
decided we'd engage in some grown-up
activities yes dinner for two
that allows me by nature I'm on the
bottom
so I can't breathe through my mouth
obviously because it's full a very deep
breath through my nose at which part of
his testicles
boom a tight seal so I can't breathe at
all
so I big-leaguer out panicking he's
thinking obviously oh he's loving babe
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know someone should maybe I need
help but I envisioned two people say
like this but something is in her mouth
why would the thing below it be in her
No
[Applause]
or go on the red bucket we're done we're
done
[Music]